Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm Jan, and
in this video I'm revealing the very best
Karate Kid easter eggs, epic call-backs, and
hidden details you might have missed in the
third season of Cobra Kai!
Spoilers ahead, of course, so take care.
Before they came up with Eagle Fang as the
name for Johnny's new dojo,
"Welcome to Eagle Fang Karate."
"Uh, eagles don't have fang.."
the show's writers tossed around various suggestions
for different animals that his character would
think of as representing strength and masculinity,
including lions.
The final idea came from Johnny's "80s mentality
and the eagle that he has on the wall of his
apartment."
And I imagine something that also influenced
the name was Johnny's love of a particular
80s military action movie that we see him
watch repeatedly:
"What are your likes?"
"I like muscle cars and Iron Eagle.
And Iron Eagle II."
As for the "Fang" part of the dojo title,
the showrunners say that's "just consistent
with [Johnny's] ignorance" and "he thinks
it sounds badass."
"You gotta swoop down like an eagle, grab
'em with your claws, and sink your fangs into
'em."
When the Country Club's kitchen staff start
dishing out spaghetti and red sauce,
"Don't skimp on that sauce."
it sets up a call-back to the original Karate
Kid movie where Daniel gets covered in that
same food after bumping into a waiter when
he sneaks into the Country Club kitchen and
sees Johnny kissing Ali on the dancefloor.
This time though, the boot's on the other
foot, as it's Johnny who arrives at the Club
for a date with Ali to find her and Daniel
together.
But, luckily for him, unlike young Daniel,
adult Johnny narrowly avoids a run-in with
the red sauce:
"Hey, watch it!
I'm wearing white here.
You think I want that all over me?"
And when Johnny makes fun of Daniel's suit,
his rival's comeback
"You should talk there, Scarface."
is a reference to Al Pacino's famous movie
role as penniless Cuban Tony Montana who becomes
a drug lord nicknamed Scarface in 1980s Miami.
The way Ali greets Daniel when she sees him,
for the first time in decades, at the Country
Club
"Daniel with an L!"
is a nod to this scene in the original movie:
"Hey, you got a name?"
"Ali, with an I.
Hey, what's your name?"
"Daniel, with an L."
And Tory does a similar thing in season 2:
"Name's Miguel."
"Tory.
With a Y."
When the LaRussos invite Cobra Kai's landlord
over for dinner to ask him to stop renting
the dojo to Kreese, the camera starts the
scene by focusing in on a dish of macaroni
and cheese.
"Macaroni and cheese?
You know what I like!
I grew up on macaroni and cheese."
The skeleton hoodie Tory wears during Cobra
Kai's brutal payback attack on Miyagi-Do is
a hat-tip to the skeleton costumes Johnny
and his crew wore to the Halloween dance
and while they were beating up Daniel afterwards
and then getting their butts kicked by Mr
Miyagi in the original movie.
And that skeleton costume actually popped
up in Season One when Johnny gave it to Miguel
to wear for his Halloween dance.
And, like Johnny all those years earlier,
Miguel also ended up in a fight that night.
In both the TV show and the original movie,
the beef between Cobra Kai and Miyagi-do also
plays out on the soccer pitch.
Dimitri deliberately trips Hawk up, just like
Bobby did to Daniel in the first movie,
and curiously, the music you hear during the
match in the series is "Rock 'n' Roll Over
You", which featured in the second film's
ice-breaking scene.
One of the fun things about Cobra Kai is getting
to see parts of the Karate Kid movies from
a different perspective
and it seems like there's a shout-out at the
school board meeting to the popular satirical
YouTube video by J Matthew Turner about Danny
being the real villain of The Karate Kid:
"When I went to school here, I was bullied,
and karate saved me."
"I heard you were the real bully!"
That's also a nod to the first season where
Johnny claimed to Miguel that he was victimised
by Daniel.
"Out of nowhere, the guy sucker punches me."
"Yeah!
Yeah!"
"What an asshole."
"I know, man."
Though this season, Daniel gives Miguel his
version of events.
"All that I knew was that he broke her radio.
She was upset.
I was being chivalrous."
And speaking of different sides to the story,
it turns out that Daniel's reason for his
and Ali's break-up,
"She tells me that she's just fallen in love
with some football player from UCLA",
was rather different to Ali's version:
"So I got into UCLA, and I ran into this guy
that I knew who went there.
Daniel sees me talking to my friend..
He jumps to conclusions."
"I thought you were in love with the guy."
And they didn't see eye-to-eye on Daniel's
'47 Ford either, with Daniel complaining to
Mr Miyagi that:
"I let Ali borrow the car, and she redesigns
my fender.
And I don't know what she did to the engine,
but that ain't running right, either."
Whereas, according to Ali:
"I told you that the brakes on Mr. Miyagi's
car were gonna go.
I hope you didn't tell him that it was my
fault it crashed?"
"No, of course not."
And when Ali calls Daniel and Johnny out over
their relentless bickering, she neatly sums
up the premise of the entire Cobra Kai show:
"You say one thing, you say the opposite.
You both think there's only one side to the
story.
There's your side, and your side, and then
there is the truth."
Talking of different viewpoints, the show
continues to include unused footage from the
original movies that's never been seen before,
as they did in the very first scene in season
one.
This season, in the flashbacks to Chozen's
final fight with Daniel, when Miyagi impresses
on him how serious the situation is, Daniel
replying 'I know' has been added to the scene.
"This not tournament.
This for real."
"I know."
When Daniel goes to Cobra Kai looking for
Johnny at the start of the season but finds
Kreese there instead,
as he enters the space he sees the phrase
"Fear Does Not Exist In This Dojo" painted
on the wall where previously Johnny's Cobra
Kai logo had been.
Those were Kreese's very first words in the
original Karate Kid movie that Danny heard
when he visited his dojo for the first time.
"Fear does not exist in this dojo, does it?"
"No, sensei!"
Adding to Danny's sense of déjà vu is a
standee of the older Kreese, similar to the
one he saw of the younger villain in the film.
In the present day, Kreese delights in rubbing
in the fact that Miguel was put in a coma
by a kid taught by Daniel.
And he uses a Mr Miyagi-ism to make the point:
"But I don't really blame Robby.
'Cause you know what they say...
there's no such thing as a bad student."
"No such thing bad student.
Only bad teacher."
Season 3 fills us in on Kreese's backstory.
And the first flashback to his youth is deliberately
set up to make us think at first that this
guy here is actually the young Kreese.
"They're the opponent.
You don't show them mercy."
And it's only when the busboy's employer shouts
at him, that we realise who he really is:
"Kreese!
The tables are not gonna bus themselves.
Get back to work!"
And a neat little inside joke that adds to
this scene's fake-out is that the guy we initially
think is Kreese is, in fact, played by Jesse
Kove, the son of actor Martin Kove, who plays
the adult Kreese.
The showrunners intentionally framed Kreese
as a "typical underdog" in this flashback
as they wanted us to see him in a different
light because, as they told EW,
"one of the [show's] central themes [...] is
redemption and looking back at these black-and-white
characters and trying to find the gray."
Another neat detail about that scene is that
it kicks off with the same kind of car that
Mr Miyagi gifted Daniel in the first film,
a '47 Ford.
"Piece of junk!
Scrap this and buy some muscle."
Although the license plate is different to
Daniel's, I wouldn't be surprised if they're
supposed to be the same car, perhaps saved
from the scrapyard.
After all, that's how Eric got his ride in
the franchise's fourth film:
"Hey, do you like my car?
I saved it from the junkyard."
The old article about Kreese from the 80s
that Robbie finds online includes a quote
from him that "Second and third place don't
count.
Which echoes his mantra from the first film,
"Defeat does not exist in this dojo",
and recalls his treatment of Johnny in the
second one:
"Second place?
Second place is no place!
You're off the team!"
And, as we see in the finale when he suggests
settling everything in the tournament, Kreese
is still goading Johnny about that second
place back in '84 all these years later, because,
notice how he looks at Johnny when he says
"if you lose":
"If you lose..."
"We won't lose."
And the second article that Robbie pulls up
about how Miyagi's dojo "defanged" Kreese's
Cobras has the same title as the newspaper
clipping that Kreese picked up then tossed
aside in the third movie.
Speaking of Johnny's Facebook photos, those
shirtless shots that Miguel tactfully turns
down for his sensei's new profile,
are actually real photos taken of William
Zabka for teen magazines during his days as
a teen idol.
The showrunners had been "ready to recreate"
a few shots, but as Zabka had "some photos
on hand that worked" they went with those.
When Chozen first shows up, his angry demeanour
suggests he's still holding a grudge against
Daniel for humiliating him in the second film,
and you can tell by Daniel's clenched fist
that he hasn't forgotten Mr Miyagi's words:
"Daniel-san, in Okinawa, honor have no time
limit."
And the way Chozen interrupts Daniel and Kumiko
just after their hands lightly brush against
each other at the bar mirrors how, in the
movie, he disturbed them just as they started
to hold hands on their date.
With actor Yuji Okumoto back as Chozen, the
show tips its hat to several of his and Daniel's
tussles from the sequel, including humorously
reversing their roles in their big fight scene
compared to the film.
"Honk."
And later, when Chozen gives Daniel one of
Mr Miyagi's scrolls,
"You keep for your collection."
that's a riff on the scene in the movie where
Kumiko pelts Chozen with a tomato after he
attacks Daniel:
"You keep for your collection.
I know you like it."
When Chozen shows Daniel around his dojo,
you can see several pictures there that are
the same as ones Daniel hung up in his dojo
last season.
In fact, this photo here is actually a real-life
martial artist from Okinawa who founded the
Gōjū-ryū school of karate.
And it's especially fitting that he appears
in the show because Robert Mark Kamen who
created the original Karate Kid characters
and wrote the first three movies trained in
that particular method and his instructor
learned it from the founder himself whose
photo we see here.
During their catch-up in Okinawa, Kumiko reveals
why London's her favourite place she's ever
visited:
"I got to see the Cranberries.
They played "Zombie," "Linger," and "Dream."
That's a nod to the franchise's fourth movie,
The Next Karate Kid,
where Hilary Swank's character Julie practises
her karate moves to the sounds of The Cranberries'
song Dreams and the monks at the Buddhist
monastery where she's staying join in dancing!
"Never trust spiritual leader who cannot dance."
And when Kumiko tells Daniel that she never
married but stayed
"a free agent",
that's a reference to how Daniel told her
he was single in the movie:
"Are you arranged?"
"What, are you kidding?
I'm a free agent."
"What is free agent?"
"Well, that just means that I'm available."
Curiously, after she left the dance company,
her life somewhat parallels her aunt Yukie's
who also taught O-Bon dance in Okinawa and
chose not to wed after her young love Mr Miyagi
left:
"Why you never marry?"
"You never come back."
"I'm supposed to believe a guy never got a
ring on that finger?"
"None of them fought to the death for me."
Which is, of course, a reference to how Chozen
took her hostage to force Daniel to fight
him.
Traci Toguchi who played the little girl Yuna
in the second film also returns.
And just as Daniel saved her during the typhoon
all those decades ago, thanks to her position
as the Senior Vice President of Sales for
Doyona she's able to return the favour and
help Daniel save his business.
Also during Daniel's trip to Okinawa, there's
an amusing shout-out to the scene in the Karate
Kid Part 2 where the young Daniel broke six
blocks of ice in a bet.
This time though, the ice is just for drinks
at a bar.
Season 2 already tipped its hat to that famous
scene when Daniel was about to perform a demonstration
to encourage new Miyagi-do students when he
was interrupted by Cobra Kai's showier demo
with fire.
Kreese may have kicked Johnny out of his own
dojo at the end of season 2, but in the first
episode of the new season, we see that Johnny
is still taking a page out of Kreese's book.
This time, he's putting his fist through car
windows during a fight, just like Kreese did
back in The Karate Kid Part 2.
And it's not just car windows that get smashed
this season, as during their fight in the
finale, Kreese throws Daniel through a windowpane
at the Cobra Kai dojo,
a call-back to when he turned up out of the
blue at the start of season 2 and ended up
kicking Johnny into one of the dojo mirrors.
All of which is a nod to Mr Miyagi's fight
with Kreese and his army pal Silver in the
Karate Kid Part 3.
Oh, and just to confirm much Cobra Kai are
taking after their new sensei,
the final episode also shows the Cobra kids
throwing Bert through the kitchen window at
the LaRusso home.
When Kreese starts to choke Johnny during
their final face-off, that's a call-back to
what he did in the second film.
He has actually had Johnny in a chokehold
in the series before now, though he was giving
a demo in a class at the time rather than
trying to beat him up.
Given he's such a fan of The Iron Eagle movie,
it's no wonder Johnny takes Miguel to a gig
by Dee Snider this season.
After all, "We're Not Gonna Take It", a song
by Snider's former heavy metal band Twisted
Sister features in that film.
And the Cobra Kai series itself used the same
song in season 1 during Johnny's unconventional
training with his students for the tournament.
When Miguel takes photos of Johnny for his
Facebook page, look at the book he's pretending
to read.
It's called The Queen of Hearts, which is
fitting because Johnny's having these photos
taken to impress his former teen love, Ali.
But also the book's about two long-time friends
who are forced to re-assess their lives when
an old flame returns out of the blue.
Now, Daniel and Johnny may not be friends
exactly but they do go way back and their
old flame Ali turning up all of a sudden does
force them to confront the truth about their
past and themselves.
"You guys are more alike than you want to
admit."
After the car wash fundraiser, the Cobra Kai
bullies wait for Nathaniel to be by himself
on his push-bike then arrive on their motorbikes
to beat him up.
Which is a throwback to when Johnny and his
Cobra Kai buds got Daniel when he was alone
on his bicycle and roughed him up by using
their motorbikes to drive him off the track.
After the big fight between the kids at Golf
'n' Stuff, Amanda confronts Kreese at his
dojo:
"Hey, Rambo.
Kids are getting hurt."
Calling Kreese 'Rambo', of course, fits his
tough, aggressive character and his Vietnam
background, but it's also a nod to the fact
that actor Martin Kove appeared in the second
film in that franchise.
When Daniel's scrolling through family photos
on his phone at the bar in Japan, I think
this picture here is Ralph Macchio with his
real-life daughter Julia.
And at the city council meeting, this looks
like a cameo from Macchio's actual son Daniel.
When the show first introduces Kreese's army
buddies, everything about this guy here points
to him being Terry Silver,
the main villain in the third movie, from
his ponytail to the shape of his face, his
whole manner and the way he talks.
"Johnny, Johnny!"
"Hey!
Johnny!
Johnny, Johnny!"
So, it's a bit of a shock when he's killed
off and the other guy Twig is revealed as
the real Silver!
"Shut your goddamn mouth, Silver!"
And Twig's line in the show,
'I owe you man',
echoes his words to Kreese in the third movie:
'I owe you, man.'
And now, with Kreese's phone call in the finale,
we look set to see the original actor who
played Silver in the movie, Thomas Ian Griffith,
back on screen with his Cobra Kai chum.
And I talk more about that in my Season 3
Ending Explained video.
Tap here to watch that or follow the link
in the video description.
And it's also interesting how the finale uses
the classic 80s song 'In The Air Tonight'
to underscore the dramatic build-up to next
season's showdown,
with the track's famous drum roll signalling
the arrival of Johnny in a moment that couldn't
be more 1980s if he was wearing an I Heart
the 80s hoodie and headband.
The lyrics, 'I've been waiting for this moment
all my life', are especially fitting and neatly
meta as not only has Kreese been craving revenge
for years,
but many fans of the show have also been hoping
for a team-up between Daniel and Johnny!
I also like the way the finale subtly tips
it hat to Daniel and Johnny's showdown at
the end of the first Karate Kid film by having
Daniel dressed in white and Johnny in black.
So, what other easter eggs, call-backs or
awesome details did you spot this season?
And what was your favourite moment?
Comment below and if you enjoyed this leave
a thumbs-up, I really appreciate it.
Tap left for my next Cobra Kai video or tap
right for something else you're sure to like.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!